Some new developments out of
Ukraine this morning
where officials
say the counteroffensive in Luhansk
is progressing.
Ukrainian forces
now controlling a key highway
in that region,
bombarding the important
Russian supply route,
leaving it unusable.
Meantime, Russia is responding
to the counter
offensive a top Russian official
threatening to hold Kiev's
electricity supply hostage,
saying power would be restored
only if Ukraine recognizes
Russia's attempted annexation.
Let's get some insight
now from retired
Lieutenant General Mark Hertling.
He's a CNN military analyst
and a former commanding general for U.S.
Army, Europe and Seventh Army General,
good morning
and thanks for being with us.
The Kremlin
threatening to take Kiev's power
supply hostage.
How seriously do you take that threat
It would certainly have a huge effect
on the nation of Ukraine, Boris.
And good morning to you.
What we're talking about
is during a really tough winter
that's coming up having been in Europe
and especially in Ukraine
during the wintertime, it is cold.
So you're talking a combination
of not only electricity, but heat,
any kind of power supplies.
It would not only contribute
to the support
of the civilian population,
but also support of the military.
So it is certainly an approach
that the Russians have used
from the very beginning,
taking away the infrastructure.
But it's going to be
particularly important
during this period of the year.
What can Ukraine and
its allies in the West
realistically do to either
prevent that or try to circumvent
some of the effects it causes?
Well,
they've been doing
quite a bit in terms
of providing air
defense support capabilities to destroy
incoming missiles and rockets
that that the Soviets are using.
And now a drones that they've received
received from Iran.
So it is all part of the counteroffensive
that Ukraine is conducting.
Unfortunately,
the Russians have fired so many
missiles, rockets, drones at all
different types of targets
in a very large area of Ukraine.
There's no pinpointed target.
So Ukraine has to defend everywhere,
and that's virtually impossible,
even though they've been very successful
in knocking down the majority.
The vast majority of the incoming rounds.
They haven't been able to knock down
all of them.
And those are the ones that
unfortunately affect the power stations.
While the
counteroffensive is making progress,
in some parts of eastern Ukraine,
they've hit snags in other parts
with these new Russian conscripts,
as well as just muddy conditions.
As you noted,
we're starting to get into winter
or closer to winter.
And the field, the landscape
is difficult for movement.
What do you make of the new developments
in that part of Ukraine?
Yeah, it's interesting, Boris.
I was just having a conversation
with a colleague about that.
Those who draw
big circles and arrows on maps
forget that those map, those arrows
sometimes have to go through
swamps and lands
that are bogged down in places
where there is no roads and forest.
So it's a whole lot easier
to draw those areas,
those arrows,
than it is to actually maneuver
in those locations.
But Ukraine has done a very good job.
Yes.
Russia is
basically stacking their defenses
with a new mobile as mobilized recruits.
But again,
those recruits are absolutely untrained.
Terrible and joining units
with low morale.
So what we're seeing really is
Russia feeding
more meat to a meat grinder.
And Russia,
Ukraine will have increased challenges
with countering
those kinds of larger units, because,
after all, quantity has a quality
all of its own.
But I think because of the capability of
Ukraine's army, they will eventually win.
They'll down.
One of the areas
is that southern area person
estimates
by the Ukrainian intelligence is
that there are close to 40,000
Russian troops
on the
western bank of the river
that have no means to escape.
So that's an area
that I'm I've been watching very closely
When you don't have the ability
to resupply,
soldiers have them escape or withdraw.
It's going to be very difficult.
And there is the huge potential
for Ukraine to capture
a great many of those soldiers
and take them completely out of action.
Feeding meat to a meat grinder.
Wow. That's that's tough.
Notably, there have been indications
from both
Republicans and Democrats in Congress
that there are doubts about maintaining
the level of support
for Ukraine that we've seen thus far.
Are you concerned with what support
for Ukraine might look like after
the midterm elections
going into a new Congress next year?
Yeah, I am, Boris.
I'm concerned
about the narrative
that some are presenting
in terms of this case.
What you're talking about
is a nation
that's fighting for its sovereignty
and for its independence.
The West has supported Ukraine
very well so far. They're increasing.
The president just gave another package
of $725 million to Ukraine
just in the last few days.
What we're talking about
is the potential
for the United States
and NATO, truthfully, to be affected
by inflationary
prices based on
what's been happening in Ukraine,
but also kind of
an overwhelming information
flow that we see sometimes.
And the public gets tired of
and there's a fatigue.
But we have to remember,
Ukrainian citizens
are fighting for their freedom,
for their sovereignty.
And we have always presented
our American values to other nations.
When you're doing that, in this case,
going against a Russian force
that actually is committing
multiple
war crimes,
and we'll either get you
illegal activity,
what you're talking about
is really having an attempt
to sustain that through
what's going to be a very tough winter.
I'm convinced that we will do that.
But it will certainly come up
in a debate in Congress
and in NATO's as well.
But the support seems to
continue to flow.
General Hertling, as
always, appreciate your expertize.
Thanks. Pleasure, Bruce. Thank you.